few people have heard of Walter pittz
despite his revolutionary ideas that
helped set the stage for artificial
intelligence he was one of the first to
show the brain function like a computer
but just when his career was taking off
a series of tragic circumstances led him
to destroy his research withdraw from
Academia and succumb to
alcoholism this is the story of the
scientist who should have been famous
but instead died alone and unknown you
could say the odds of Walter pittz
becoming a scientist were not in his
favor born in Detroit on April 23 1923
his father and brothers were rough and
uneducated his dad actually wanted him
to quit school to get a job but Walter
was brilliant as a child he taught
himself to read Latin Greek and Sanskrit
he found soulless in math with logic
being the antidote to his chaotic Life
The Story Goes that while hiding from
bullies one day at the age of 12 he ran
into the library and stumbled upon a
copy of prip Mathematica a three volume
work that tried to show that all math
can be explained by using pure logic he
didn't leave the library even after
closing for the next 3 days Walter
poured over the 2,000 pages and sent a
letter to its co-author bertran Russell
pointing out what he considered mistakes
in his work 3 years later when he was 15
and heard bertran was going to be
lecturing at the University of Chicago
he ran away from home and went off to
Illinois he never spoke with his family
again except for sending home an
anonymous Christmas present every year
for the next few years he was
unofficially enrolled at the University
of Chicago while hanging around campus a
young medical student he befriended
Jerome or Jerry lein introduced him to
Warren mulik a professor of Psychiatry
at the University of Illinois molik
wanted to learn how the brain worked
delving into the process by which the
firing of neurons transforms into
thoughts Walter understood what was
required and knew how to model it
mathematically mullik took him under his
wing and into his home where they
tackled this question their
groundbreaking paper in 1943 envisioned
the brain as a collection of tiny
switches each one turning on or off like
a light bulb and these switches working
together to create thoughts and
decisions mullik eagerly declared to a
group of philosophy students for the
first time in the history of science we
know how we know it marked the first
time anyone seriously likened the brain
to a computer they ins into how neurons
operate paved the way for the creation
of neural networks now Central to the
machine learning Revolution
mathematician John Von Newman based his
design on one of the earliest electronic
computers on Pitts in molck model of the
brain Walter pittz was a rising star
Fortune Magazine included him in its
list of the top 10 Young scientists at
us universities in 1954 he shot away
from this type of public attention
seldom even signing his name to anything
following his groundbreaking paper his
friend Jerry Lin once again played a
crucial role in introducing him to
another influential scientist this time
the renowned mathematician Norbert
weiner at MIT who pioneered the field of
cybernetics the study of how humans and
machines control and communicate
information Walter moved to Boston after
working on the Manhattan Project during
the War years to work for weiner whom he
regarded as a father figure during their
initial meeting weiner didn't say hello
but instead walked Walter over to a
Blackboard where he was working out a
complex mathematical problem Walter
chimed in with questions and suggestions
and Weiner was impressed by the young
man he later exclaimed that Walter was
without question the strongest young
scientist whom I have ever met I should
be extremely astonished if he does not
prove to be one of the two or three most
important scientists of his generation
not merely in America but in the World
At Large he had profound confidence in
Walter's abilities and believed his
neural networks could be implemented
into man-made machines but although
Walter's work with mullik was
revolutionary it was an overly
simplified representation of the brain
weiner wanted him to make his model more
realistic he promised Walter a PhD
despite the fact that he hadn't even
graduated high school Walter's PhD
thesis focused on developing an advanced
version of his earlier brain model using
three-dimensional neural networks which
was incredibly challenging and involved
some very complicated math but those
inum were sure he'd succeed instead of
Walter's career taking off however it
Came Crashing Down When weener suddenly
cut ties with it because Walter was
close to mulik whom weiner hated the
rift began when the director of mit's
research laboratory of electronics
invited mullik to lead a new brain
research project at MIT Walter along
with his friend Jerry letvin and a young
neuroscientist named Patrick Wall were
part of the team exploring how the
nervous system processes information and
how machines might mimic these functions
just as they were delving deeper into
the brain's workings Wier withdrew his
support from the group reportedly
because his wife disapproved of molik
who had a pension for alcohol and wild
parties Margaret weiner is said to have
invented a story and told her husband
that when their daughter Barbara stayed
at mullock's house several of his boys
had seduced her it's been suggested
Margaret thought mullock's rise would
threaten Weiner's prominence at MIT we
immediately sent an angry telegram to
the MIT director please inform hitson
lein that all connection between me and
your projects is permanently abolished
they are your problem weer abandoned
Walter the young man whom he had taken
under his wing the final nail in the
coffin for Walter pittz came during a
heartbreaking experiment involving frogs
while it was believed that the eye took
in information and sent it to the brain
for analysis Walter's experiment found
that the Frog's eye itself processed
visual information like movement before
passing it on to the brain this
contradicted Walter's simpler logical
model of the brain in which he theorized
that the brain was the primary Center
for processing all sensory information
turns out reality was much more complex
lein recalled that the results
disappointed Walter he would never admit
it but it seemed to add to his despair
at the loss of wier's friendship Walter
destroyed his thesis all of his research
all of his life's work with the
exception of writing one more paper he
did little else but drink for the next
10 years yaan was his interest in
science gone were his interests in
anything he had been curious about from
poetry to geology to the birds of New
England in the 1950s he moved out of
Jerry lean's home because his heavy
drinking scared his friends's children
he spent the 60s in Boston's bars
changing his venue frequently so that
his friends couldn't find it he was in
such a bad state that he couldn't take
care of his only companion his dog on
May 14
1969 Walter pittz died alone of alcohol
rated causes in a boarding house in
Cambridge Massachusetts he was just 46
years old pits knowingly set the stage
for modern Computing in machine learning
shaping a future that is still evolving
rapidly today sadly we'll never know how
much further progress might have been
achieved had his journey not been
prematurely cut short Walter Pit's
Innovations had the power to change the
world if you've been inspired to make a
significant impact in our digital era or
want to brush up on your math computer
science and data science skills I highly
recommend brilliant brilliant is the
best way to learn stem interactively and
it's free for you to try out unlike
spending years in a traditional
classroom brilliant offer is a Hands-On
approach to learning their new thinking
in code course gets you designing simple
programs to solve real world problems
like writing a program that reminds you
to exercise throughout the day as we
live in a datadriven world data sets are
only getting more in demand Brilliance
data analysis fundamentals course will
help you build your skill set by
focusing on the best ways to visualize
and interpret data sets you can try out
brilliant for free for 30 days by
clicking the custom link in my
description if you're one of the first
200 people to sign up for brilliant's
premium subscription which gives you
access to their thousands of offerings
you'll get 20% off your annual
subscription thanks for watching for
news think I'm Cindy pal